now what I've done is
just a moment what I've done is
it sounds often like I'm knocking other
teachers but
I was in this period of a site of Senses
Aikido
other people will be in this period
other people will be before my period
And as cytosansi develops and changes
the his body
his ideal changes so I was taught that
when you do this the foot
and the cup come together
they've tried to change me over the
years
to step cut because it gives you better
balance and you build mass
okay so they'll go yeah
but you see that doesn't sit with me
because I was in the era where
use your foot and Cat goes together so I
can't get rid of that because I was
taught it by side to sensei in those
days
so what I say to people is look you step
and cut because you got mass and I agree
with you because I see most people that
they don't have mass you know when Danny
holds me I can tell he's got Mass
but a lot of you don't have mass
so I've decided over the years I want to
keep that
timing because that's in me you know
that send me to where I am today
and what I didn't see what cytosense he
kept saying was Ronnie
what I didn't see from side to sense it
was
please go past and only just
you see if we're on this line and I say
do I
please please go past
see I'm still on the line he actually
has to get off the line
so it finally twigged I don't know how
many years since you must say it but
when he says dojo
see Ronnie stayed on the line and I got
off the line
so that's the second thing that I really
treasured because it took me so long to
understand
but some of you might like that and say
I'm going to make that like in my Bible
now no matter what any other teacher
tells me I'm going to be stubborn and
stick with that if any of you are
telling me you're not stubborn you're
not from this planet
so so so in other words you build your
Aikido on beliefs or else you're going
to be following teachers forever if you
think that they're going to give you the
answer they're not you've got a bit so
all of these techniques that we learned
today I've got
timing of body and feet
so watch this for on this one watch this
right foot on this one
can cut timing feet now I'm not saying
these other teachers are wrong all I'm
saying is they were taught in a
different era and theirs is more
I think it's better for the student to
learn
but I don't want to be the student
anymore I want to be Tony and I want to
be good
so I have to break out of being a
student always going please Scentsy
please Scentsy teach me and I have to be
Tony who's Tony you know so so
I've got the I've got the timing but now
I've got those or please go past Ronnie
if I sort of if I say please go past but
I've got to do this technique so I can't
leave too much space
then I'm not believing in
what I should be doing so here I go
those are
and I'm holding him off
you can't feel it but
I'm holding him off
from coming in and just keeping enough
there that
okay
so that's you know I'd love to see some
of you get that because I've got it
through being me
and not realizing oh blimey I've heard
him say that so many times I didn't
realize the essence of it
all right control come up
come up
I'll keep coming don't don't get don't
get tired
all right you don't know what's going on
in my head and I'm like I'm like Fork
lightning I'm down there I'm going
I'm working out every twitch he's doing
I'm working out electrical angle
all right so a bit too heavy for today
isn't it but
so if you think you're turning over but
then it goes over that way a little bit
you're not actually getting out the way
because then you bring it back here
and it might be subtle but that's what
as a teacher I'm trying to give you
subtlety
okay so we'll try again
you don't have to think exactly what I
think but you know make sure you're not
in their way they should they should be
able to keep going and you should be
able to do the technique
there's this one
there's this one well I'm still getting
out the way but the right time in that
one comes in
so you can play around I don't care how
many variations I say I normally see a
lot of variations when you're trying to
do it my way anyhow
thank you